mike pence
a loyal vice president to
donald trump
seems to be
hitting the campaign trail to set the
stage for a 2024 presidential bid
and he is distinguishing himself from
donald trump he is saying conservatives
need to cut it out with the attacks on
the fbi
earlier today and elsewhere i
i also want to remind my fellow
republicans
we can hold the attorney general
accountable for the decision that he
made
without attacking rank and file law
enforcement personnel at the fbi
[Applause]
the republican party is the party of law
and order
our party stands with the men and women
who serve on the thin blue line at the
federal and state and local level
and these attacks on the fbi must stop
calls to defund the fbi are just as
wrong as calls to defund the police
the truth the matter is
we need to get to the bottom of what
happened
we need to let the facts
play out
i like mike pence he's a nice guy i
think he was a good governor of indiana
he's just completely wrong here this is
just totally wrong totally
misunderstanding
the facts
and misunderstanding the political
moment the responsible thing to do
after the
outright lawlessness that we have seen
from the fbi over the last five six
seven years
the responsible thing to do is call for
dismantling it
if not ripping it up root and branch at
the very least fundamentally
restructuring it
the fbi
at the at the behest of the doj
for seven years now
made up evidence for a fisa court spied
on trump's campaign call let's not
forget let's fast forward a little bit
called parents domestic terrorists
if they don't want their kids to get
trans at school and don't want their
kids to learn that white people are evil
because of their race they're domestic
terrorists we were told
fbi at the behest of the doj raids the
home of a former president and the chief
political rival to the current president
the fbi and the doj work in collusion
with democrats a democrat-funded dossier
to set up donald trump to stop him from
being from president to undermine our
democracy and you say we can't raise any
questions and then what he does there is
he actually uses the same line that the
democrats use they say if you attack the
political leadership of the fbi and the
doj you're attacking the rank and file
officers i don't think that's true i
don't hear anybody attacking the rank
and file fbi officers who are going out
there and arresting
drug smugglers and child pornographers
and sex traffickers no i hear people
going after the political leadership of
those two institutions
rightly so
that's
in a similar way
you saw this during the bush
administration
any criticism of the political
leadership
any criticism of the way that that war
was being conducted was turned into an
attack on the troops so rhetorically i
guess it can be useful but it's not a
good argument at all especially oh my
gosh we're talking about the fbi right
now
the fbi actually going in and raiding
the homes of democrats political
opponents
completely misunderstanding the
situation completely misunderstanding
the moment i think it's probably an
honest mistake from mike pence he seems
like a good honorable guy i don't really
know him but he seems like a good
honorable guy
and he seems like he wants to be
president so i don't i don't know why he
would uh why he would be running on a
platform that's just so politically tone
deaf
and wrong on the facts but
not not a good look if if the man wants
to be president that that is not the way
to do it
i'm glad you like that clip now whoop
hold up yeah we got a million subscribed
we have over a million subscribers now
that's great it's not good enough we got
to keep pushing
we need a billion subscribers
we're only going to do that if you ring
that bell right now
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]